Dadi Perlmutter, thank you so much
for joining me on my show.
How are you?
I'm good. Very well.
Working extremely efficiently from home.
Working ... you don't have to walk
from meeting to meeting.
You must be saving some time.
Yeah.
I love it.
I'm walking more.
That's what I hear a lot,
but now, I'm actually I'm curious
to see what will happen
As we move forward,
the productivity increases,
but whether we'll get
some fatigue from this,
I think it'll be
a very interesting question.
But, Dadi, I'm not gonna waste time
talking about what's happening now
because I have the honor and pleasure
of speaking to you now.
You've spent over 30 years
at Intel Corporation.
Your last activity there
was acting as executive vice president
and chief product officer
of Intel Corporation.
Dadi, just for my ...
how many people are at Intel globally
around or at least
when you were there?
About 100,000.
About 100,000 people.
As executive vice president and CPO,
I believe I saw somewhere
that about 30,000 people
were under your command?
35,000.
Dadi, I'm gonna spend 20 minutes
on a single question,
but actually I have many more questions.
But what is it like
running 35,000 people
as executive vice president of Intel?
It's very difficult.
And I think ...
That's why I can work
from remote much easier,
because you find out that you have
Andy Grove said something,
when you manage something
so complex, so far,
you have to influence people
because you cannot talk to each person
and change his mind.
So, you have to be
much more into influencing.
So example, be very precise and
very concise about what you say
and how you say.
I ... my Israeli officer
that you have to be in the lines
every once in a while,
to talk to people in the line,
to make sure that you know exactly
who they are
because the problem is
that you ... the information
from your people,
which is very important.
So I think that
it's such a rare opportunity
to speak to somebody
who's managed 35,000 people.
I often ask entrepreneurs and founders
about leadership and about
what is it like running a team
of 12, 13 people
as you go through the trenches
of a startup.
What are the difficulties
and the challenges
of running 35,000 people?
I mean, how do you lead
a group of 35,000 people?
Do they know you?
Do they know who Dadi is?
Are you just this guy in the background
making the decisions?
How does it work?
Well I manage also five, six people teams,
so I know the difference.
It's a huge difference.
When you manage five, six, 10 people
usually you're all together,
and if you're a startup,
you mostly know
many of the people for years
and you're good friends with them.
Right.
And it's very different
when you run 35,000
across probably four continents
or something like that.
I learned something from,
someone asked Mahatma Gandhi,
"How do you lead for 400 million people?"
At that time, there had been only
400 million Indians at the time.
He said,
"I'm not leading them;
I'm seeing where the people are running
and I'm just running in front of them."
You come to realize that
most of the people, other than people
that work really closely with you,
and with many of the people
I've been working for dozens of years,
the people have the persona of you.
They have the impression of who you are.
Which may not be,
or probably, not exactly who you are.
Or, as I said, people have many personas.
It's not that you are schizophrenic
or something like that,
but you have many persona because,
my kids see a different Dadi
than my wife is,
and where my friends are,
and my employees are.
But at the end of the day,
you're the same person.
My leadership style
that I'm open and direct.
People know what I mean when I say.
They don't have to second guess me.
Makes it easier for them
to understand what I'm talking about.
That's my ... you don't trick them.
And you show by example.
Is it possible to be open and direct
with 30,000 people?
Yes, because if you admit
when you make mistakes,
and if you do it every day,
it's a problem.
Right.
... don't want to be led by an idiot
that change his mind every day.
But, every once in a while,
you make a bad move
and human beings make bad decisions.
I believe that a good leader
is not one that does not make a mistake
because all people are.
is ... admit openly about the mistake,
learn from the mistakes,
and direct a new course of action
because, not because you are idiots,
you don't know what to do.
Maybe you are idiots,
but I'm also part of the team of idiots
and this is why I made a mistake.
This is what happened.
This is what I'm going to do next.
And I have a big lecture about this one.
But my greatest achievement,
Intel is a ...
was based on a big failure
that we learned from the mistake
and applied
You know the whole Intel notebook,
the Centrino program,
was based on a failed program
that was codenamed Timna.
And it was a big failure,
and a huge success.
And today it's a core core part
and part of all of the-
Now, it is the foundation
of what became the core.
But as a matter of fact, at that time,
only 50% of people use notebooks.
Today, 90% of people buy notebooks
when they use a personal computer.
I was having a wonderful conversation
the other day with Gil Frostig
who you probably know from Intel as well.
And he's a very good friend here
from J-Ventures.
And we were talking about his endeavors
with Wi-Fi chips and how that also
came from not a mistake,
but some consequence
that he did not expect.
But, Dadi, I want to take you then
back to you're at the Technion,
you're studying electrical engineering,
you're joining Intel.
Eventually, you come to speak about
how one of the great things
about this cooperation
between Intel and the Technion is that
while they're both situated
in very close proximity,
but the best and the brightest
from the Technion
often go to work at Intel.
And you're creating something
very special there
within the startup nation.
Take me back to those times.
You join Intel.
Do you have an aspiration
to go and spend over 30 years
at this great corporation
and rise the ladder of success
to be one of the executives?
Is that intentional?
No. I came to Intel as a compromise
because I really wanted to be an academic.
I wanted to be a professor.
So, you settled
for going on a career path for executive.
I like that.
I was very very young.
I basically was married
when I studied in the Technion.
My eldest son was already born.
And when talking to my wife I said
I want to go to do my masters
and then PhD. She said,
"Well, you know we are
in a bad financial situation.
We have to get stable a little bit."
And we decided
that I'll go to work at Intel
and continue my studies
as an external student.
Wow.
And so maybe two, three years,
we get stabilized.
I never finished my masters degree.
And I spent 34 years at Intel.
But every three, four years
was a completely different journey.
And that doesn't stop you
from now teaching and inspiring
thousands on the Coursera course
that I came across.
So, I think that
the masters degree will wait.
Dadi, I want to make sure
we have enough time for this.
I want to do a transition now
to the time after Intel.
And one of the things that is very evident
when you look at your background
and the things that you're doing
is that you're very passionate about
social entrepreneurship,
social innovation, both as the
chairman of the board of Mishelanu,
but also chairman of the board
of Israel Innovation Authority
and I'm probably missing
a bunch of others
that I didn't mention here.
What is this transition
from an executive vice president at Intel
to being the chairman of the board
of these organizations?
And what does that even mean
being the chairman of the board?
For me, it is very simple
because it's the same thing.
Basically, the one thing that eventually
got me to say I think that
because my dream was to make things
that change the world.
That's my dream.
Since I was a child.
I thought I'll do it as an academic,
then as an engineer,
eventually as an executive
in a big company.
But there are other things to do
other than computing.
And basically computing and technology
could be used for bad things
in many cases,
but also for good things.
And I'm focusing on Israel.
But most of these problems
are worldwide issues,
and basically my wife and I decided
that we'd devote a big portion of our time
and all of our philanthropic investment
into social entrepreneurship,
predominantly in education,
closing social gaps,
giving opportunities, and combining
or making communities closer.
So, one of the I'm a chairman also
of a nonprofit that deals with
bringing the Arab community in Israel
into Israeli high tech.
So, it's all the same.
People are different,
but it's all about working with people
with motivation to do great things.
So, inspire me a little
with some of the things
that you're deeply passionate about.
Some things that you know
I, as a young entrepreneur
now here in Palo Alto or from Tel Aviv,
that I might not be exposed to
on a day to day basis.
These are issues
that are very close to my heart as well
because all the way through high school
and the military,
I was also very active and very passionate at
bringing together various communities.
But I'd love to get your take,
because now you're getting an exposure
at this from an executive level
as you're overseeing
a lot of these organizations
that are doing a
really amazing impact.
So, what are some of the things
that I, as young entrepreneur,
can take with me and understand better
about my society?
And what is my potential role as a leader
as I go into the high tech industry,
hopefully make a positive impact,
but I also have a social responsibility
to bridge together communities
and not be a bystander and let the same
circle of effect take place.
Unfortunately, the world is using
... possibilities for you
if you want to do things.
We picked education because education,
at the end of the day, is the
you can argue masters degree, yes, no,
but this is,
for most of the kids in the world,
this is just.
Every child have a huge intelligence.
In the US, they have the saying that
we could very much
anticipate your success
in school and in life
based on the zip code.
And the zip code is not, is an indicator
of how wealthy your parents are.
It has nothing to do with you,
your intelligence, your abilities.
So, giving opportunities.
If you want to change the world,
one of the ways, which takes longer,
is to give opportunities
for kids in school.
And it's amazing.
One of the organizations
that my wife and I are doing,
they take schools
in the wrong zip codes.
And it's amazing how smart
the team of people with relatively
small amount of money
are able to make changes
from a 20% success
in academic successes
into 80 and even 90% in three, four years.
What is the changing factor?
What changes from 20 to 80%?
It's a complex way,
but it's a very much
a very systematic view
of people ... education
combined with people
that come from the high tech community.
They go, it sounds like an ...
My wife is an educator.
She was a principal
of a special ed school.
They go in with the right people,
good pedagogy, they do a few things.
First, the schoolmaster is the king.
They are not doing
the plans for him or her.
The ownership is the schoolmaster.
It's a big difference.
In Israel, especially,
the minister of education
tells the schoolmaster
what he needs to do, or she.
... is she,
so I'll use she from now on.
They bring in a set of volunteers.
They come from high tech business,
army, 81 and 82.
They make miracles in helping kids
to go study the highest level of math
and go to what ... examinations.
And they are same age, give or take.
So, it's not the 60 plus years old
tell them what to do.
[crosstalk]
It's a big influence.
We bring what we call a mentor
for the schoolmaster.
Someone from,
we have an Army lieutenant general
is one of those. He sits there
and the schoolmaster calls him
and they get help.
And the pedagogic team comes in
and do a deep analysis of the school.
Not just the pedagogic
and academic successes,
social situation,
the level of the teachers,
the teamwork between the schoolmaster
and the teachers,
the situation at home.
Many of these kids go at home
that have one parent
and not two, social economic issues.
And they eventually based on this data,
and they have huge amount of information,
and the schoolmaster always say,
"I have never seen such a deep analysis
to understand the school
that I'm running for five, six years."
And it's classical,
basic engineer, call it that way.
And then they support the schoolmaster.
We give them some money,
not a huge amount.
But you don't come as a consultant.
You come and you say,
"I'll help you implement the plan.
You create"
So Dadi, while this is remarkable
and inspiring, I see a dissonance.
On one hand,
you're overseeing an operation
of 35,000 people.
Chief product officer of intel.
You're running billions of dollars, right,
in terms of both talent
but also in terms of products.
So, you're used
to making decisions at scale, right?
Like high level.
Like, how do we go about the world.
Now you're talking to me.
How do we go into a single school
and influence kids
that you can count on a piece of paper.
And so, is that intentional?
Because you could be spending
your time right now
sitting on the boards of unicorns
that are dealing with billions of people.
And you're choosing
to spend your time and effort
on this mentorship activity
for specific people.
Well, the truth of the matter
One, I do also,
I'm a chairman of two startups
and I'm also investors in a few others.
So, my day is full. My main job-
But Dadi, I just want to make sure.
But when you go
and you look Dadi up online, what exudes
is your philanthropic activities.
It's not the investments
and it's not the board.
It's the volunteering work
that you are doing.
I agree. And I'll tell you what.
My main job in this nonprofit,
my wife do this,
she ... with 10 schools
so she's a big manager too.
A big challenge and one of the things
that I work very closely
with the CEO of this nonprofit,
an impressive lady,
is about scale.
Because we are now dealing,
when my wife and I joined, we dealt with
about seven or eight schools.
We're now dealing with 40.
All of the big,
looks insurmountable right now
is how to influence
the minister of education
to change her mind,
because at the end of the day, in Israel,
there are about
800 to a 1000 schools like this.
So, 40 schools it's still a drop.
But there's an old saying in Hebrew that
the one who saves the life of one person
is if he changes the life
of save the life of the whole world.
So, every kid matters.
So, it's not a small deal.
It's more important
than billions of dollars.
I always ... to
my wife the third job
in saving kid's life
literally in her school
- Amazing
is bigger job
than my billions of dollars.
But you have to say
that everything that I do,
with every non-profit that I work with,
is about scale, not just the one person.
Nevertheless, the one person
is still extremely important.
Dadi, so much inspiration here.
Before we leave,
you've been an integral part
of the startup nation
and the foundation of the startup nation
from its early days.
What is the startup nation?
What is this miracle
of this tech innovation
in Israel beyond Intel?
You've seen it.
You've lived it.
Why is Israel a big tech hub?
Well, I'll tell you.
First, Israel is not a startup nation.
There is a nation within Israel
called startup nation,
which is about 9% of the people
in the country.
My job, talking just about education,
is hopefully to turn the whole Israel
into a startup nation.
Not meaning that everybody works
on a startup and inventing technology,
but the world is becoming more
based on technology,
and people who are not technology literate
are not going to be able
to succeed in this world.
And the corona crisis
even exemplified that even further.
20 years ago, I was interviewed
in New Delhi.
They wanted to turn India
into the IT nation.
And they talk about Intel of course,
and all that.
And his last question was
the same question you asked;
what do we in India need to do?
And I said
What you are doing good in Israel.
I said,
"That means you don't understand
Israeli culture."
If you ask me what's bad in Israel,
I'll give you a 15 minute lecture
without even thinking.
- 15 hours
If you want to ask me what's good,
give me five minutes to think.
It's about the impatience,
the wanting to do things better,
wanting to do things differently,
not being confined to the box.
Right.
And so, I said it's very short,
but it's very, it's very easily
the camaraderie on one hand
and the personal success
on the other hand.
So I've seen culture that
go either on camaraderie,
or the personal inspiration.
And in Israel, it's something
which is quite unique.
And it's very difficult to explain
because how can you be driving
your own personal success?
Is it on the expense of the camaraderie?
Never will be at the expense of the team
in especially successful.
That's one of the reasons for success.
I love it.
When I always think about this question,
first, I obviously go back
to my own military service
and I can't help but remember
all the times where
I was leading a team of engineers.
My commander would come in and say,
"Michael, here is the task.
We need this software
to be done next week."
And I'm saying,
"But we need three times the people
in order to get this done."
And he's like,
"No. You'll figure out a way. I trust you.
Come back next week."
And obviously you figure out a way,
but I also think back to Ben Gurion
and I don't know if it's a myth
or if it's a real story
that we ran out of rice.
And so he said,
"Figure out a way."
And that's how he came
to make ptitim,
my favorite food of all time.
I had a boss, he was Chinese.
A very harsh person.
And I came to ask him about
... me better information
about competition at the time was digital
in the 90s.
And he said,
"What you asking me?
You're Israelis.
I'm sure you or one of you guys know
someone in Boston
that works with digital and you know the information.
Come back next month
and tell me what you do."
I love it. I love it.
Dadi, thank you so much for your time.
I know you're so busy
so I really really want to thank you.
Before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I'll tell you what my father used to say
when I was a kid
and he asked me to walk in our garden
to do gardening, which I hated. He said,
"You are an ambitious, lazy person.
You are thinking
how to do things easier."
I love it. I love it.
Dadi, thank you very very much
and stay safe and stay healthy.
And really, thank you for your time.
Really appreciate it.
- Thank you Michael.
Have fun. Bye.